more than 12 months on
and still recovering
at this long covey clinic in bristol
donna is receiving physio
she has a tight chest and shortness of
breath
my this isn't my voice this is my
covered chest
um so yeah i've got a continuation of
sort of pressure on the chest and
um just inflammation really
so where would you rate yourself on
there donna contracted kovid19
in march last year at the start of the
pandemic her gp referred her through the
long covid clinic system
but she says help wasn't easy to find at
first
i don't think the long cover clinic is
particularly visible would be my first
experience with it um
you know sort of myself and a friend did
some research um
and then he he let me know that he had
had a referral so i chased it up with my
gp who who gave me a referral
so i think particularly there's an issue
with visibility
to improve access 34 million pounds has
now been spent to open
83 clinics across england the first of
which opened
last december nhs england says it
doesn't yet have
solid figures on how many people have
actually used
the long covert clinics we've seen the
numbers of just
five of the 83 which show more than 2
000 people have already been treated
those in charge of the clinics say
demand could mean the service will be
needed well beyond
current funding so we recognize that you
know this is a condition that
the symptoms can be quite prolonged and
we've already seen that from the
patients who
got long covered now about a year ago
some people are still suffering
so there is that sort of time frame to
bear in mind so that is why
additional money has gone in to keep the
clinics going for the course of the next
year
we suspect it may need to go on for much
longer than that
we now have a clinic called the long
cover clinic
north somerset another referral louise's
coveted symptoms have lasted more than a
year
fatigue really is the main thing now
i've got two children a one-year-old
a sorry two-year-old and a four-year-old
and
it's just very very difficult to get
through
the whole day i've had to accept it
um but yeah it's been it was
a shock to the system and what i need
you to do
is walk on the spots for 40 steps okay
ready steady go new coveted infections
are falling dramatically
left behind are the so-called long
haulers
thousands who may need treatment long
after this pandemic has ended
dan whitehead sky news in bristol